[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et la rentrée
de votre hebdomadaire bienvenue dans
cette suite l'hebdo le résumé de
l'actualité de votre semaine dans les
yvelines
voici les titres de ce vendredi en
septembre le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines pierre bédier
vient d'annoncer un nouveau programme
d'investissement pour les collèges avec
un objectif réduire de 40 % leur
empreinte carbone il a également promis
l'accès aux passe plus pour les jeunes
vinoy mutilation vers les chevaux
violence envers les élus mais aussi un
dispositif pour mieux respirer créé par
suez voilà ce qui a fait l'actualité
cette semaine dans les yvelines après le
témoignage de xavier quintin je guéris
de lakovic 19
marion sinaly directrice départementale
de la rs reviendra avec nous en fin
d'émission sur les trois jours de
dépistage au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines dans l'actualité
donc je vous le disais ce jeudi 10
septembre était dévoilée au collège
romain rolland à sartrouville
le nouveau programme d'investissement du
département des yvelines
l'accent est mis sur la réduction de
l'empreinte carbone des collèges autre
annonce les jeunes vinoy auront accès
aux passe plus reportage de marie
pannetrat et de patrick jacques de
dixmude rénover ou construire quinze
collèges c'est l'objectif annoncé par le
département
les travaux sont prévus entre 2023 et
2026 le but réduire de 40% l'empreinte
carbone des collèges les quinze collèges
choisissons 15 collèges qui sont des
trappes énergétique et nous allons dès
reconstruire selon des normes
environnementales nouvelle c'est à dire
en utilisant des matériaux biosourcés
comme on dit
lui c'est à dire du bois du chambre etc
le département investit 525 millions
d'euros dans le projet deuxième annonce
l'accès aux passe plus pour les jeunes
yvelinois un service interdépartemental
avec les hauts de seine
il est accessible collégiens et lycéens
dès la rentrée en sixième jusqu'à leur
majorité
nous allons consacrer cette année et
toutes les années qui viennent 5
millions d'euros pour proposer à 160
mille jeunes se passe entre 80 et 100
euros qui leur permettra d' adhérer et
donc d'avoir les services de 2000
structures sportives ou culturelles dans
le département de guiglo
seule condition pour avoir accès aux
passes être domiciliés ou scolarisés
dans l'un des deux départements
trois cent mille jeunes sont concernés
dans l'actualité également le maire de
rosny sur seine pierre-yves du moulin
vient d'instaurer un couvre-feu pour les
moins de 15 ans il est désormais
interdit et ce jusqu'au 2 novembre les
sorties non accompagnés entre 22h et 6h
du matin cela fait suite à une
augmentation des dégradations et des
incivilités et ce vendredi 11 septembre
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin ainsi que la déléguée en charge
de la citoyenneté margaine chapa était
en visite dans le département
ils ont par dont ils ont assisté à la
cérémonie de prise de fonction de pascal
regnauld du bois la nouvelle directrice
centrale des crs
elle est d'ailleurs la première femme à
être nommée à ce poste
nous y reviendrons lundi dans le 7-8
journal
revenons maintenant sur ce qui a fait
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
mardi 8 septembre les mutilations envers
les équidés qui se multiplient en france
faisait l'actualité les yvelines
n'échappe pas à ce phénomène
face à cela propriétaire et forces de
l'ordre se mobilisent
reportage de marie pannetrat et astrid
bergère dans les yvelines
cinq cas ont été recensés depuis le mois
d'avril inquiets les propriétaires
d'équidés met tout en oeuvre pour
protéger leurs chevaux et leurs
structures d'éventuels les attaquent la
partie écuries étaient déjà sécurisé
avec des caméras remet et aujourd'hui on
va essayer de remettre des caméras de re
sécuriser la partie pré rida parti va
qui est la plus le plus vulnérable au
jour d'aujourd'hui
et en ce moment on a un maître chien
vizille une société de gardiennage qui
viennent toutes les nuits janvier les
prairies et le poney club
un dispositif essentiel pour le
directeur des écuries mais qui a un coût
c'est un
un surcoût énorme pour les écuries mais
on veut rassurer nos clients on a des
chevaux de propriétaires on a les
chevaux du poney club des enfants qui
viennent toutes les semaines il faut
pour la rentrée puis se retrouver tous
les poneys qui connaissent des groupes
facebook fermé ont aussi été créés ils
permettent de signaler tout comportement
suspect aux abords des centres équestres
et des prix dans les yvelines
deux cavaliers de la garde républicaine
ont notamment pour mission de faire de
la prévention auprès des et qui tend il
les appelle à ne pas se faire justice
eux mêmes la solution c'est plutôt vers
le 17 pour vous préserver de l'agression
enfers de 17 et prendre un maximum de
renseignements visuellement en une
plaque d'immatriculation ne pas rentrer
en contact avec cette personne
les gendarmes ont multiplié leurs
services tournés vers le monde de
l'équitation
nous renforçons le contact auprès des
éleveurs des différents centres
équestres mais aussi des différents et
qui tend à fin de l'heure de tenir une
conduite à suivre mais aussi les
rassurer au maximum afin de d'éviter
qu'ils qu'ils paniquent
quoi qu'il en soit quinze mille chevaux
et 800 propriétaires vivent dans les
yvelines la gendarmerie les invite à se
manifester pour se faire enregistrer
dans leur base de données
mercredi 9 septembre nous vous
rappelions que 91 % de la population
mondiale respire un air pollué
selon un rapport de l' oms datant de
c'est dans ce contexte qu'a été lancée à
poissy un dispositif de prêts mettant
pardon de créer une bulle d'air dans une
cour d'école
reportage de célia ncaa tsongo et de
justine rasé rendre les cours d'écoles
moins polluer c'est l'objectif de ce
dispositif innovant installé depuis une
semaine dans la cour de récréation de
l'école victor hugo à poissy dans le
cadre de la journée internationale de
l'air pur lundi 7 septembre la
présidente de la région ile de france le
maire de la ville et la directrice
générale
adjointe de suez sont venus inaugurer
cette machine qui permet de créer une
bulle d'air pur pour les enfants ce
dispositif va donc permettre de capter
de nombreux polluants l'équivalent de
ceux qui émettent en moyenne 550
véhicule sur un trajet franciliens
quotidien les particules fines pm10 et
pm2 nmi/pmi ça va être aussi le dioxyde
d'azoté
le no2 et ça va être aussi les composés
organiques volatils mais c'est vrai
c'est les polluants principaux qu'on
retrouve dans les villes et aussi dans
les écoles en juillet 2020 l'état a été
condamné pour son inaction concernant la
pollution de l'air alors pour encourager
ces projets environnementaux
la région ile-de-france a mis sur la
table 500 millions d'euros grâce au
budget participatif environnemental de
la région toutes les communes qui
décideraient de se lancer pour
développer ce dispositif pourront
déposer des projets et pouvant se faire
financer ce dispositif
pour ce premier essai l'école victor
hugo en plein centre de poissy n'a pas
été choisie au hasard
on est en plein coeur du centre-ville où
il ya des milliers des milliers de
voitures qui traversent la ville comme
les poids lourds qui n'ont rien à faire
ici en matière de circulation de transit
on a choisi ici parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de passage et on veut pouvoir montrer
qu'on peut purifier l'air avec des idées
qui sont innovants
ce premier dispositif tests s'ils
fonctionnent pourrait se retrouver
prochainement dans le regard dans les
métros ou d'en couvrir par principe
insultes menaces et même parfois
agressions physiques
jeudi 10 septembre nous vous parlions de
la violence envers les élus qu'ils
augmentent en france entre janvier et
juillet 2020 233 mer ont subi des
violences selon l'association des maires
de france
un phénomène qui inquiète aussi dans les
yvelines reportage
le 30 août dernier sami damerdji maire
de mantes la ville est menacée de mort
par un tag devant son hôtel de ville
début juillet son confrère de mantes la
jolie raphaël cogner faisait face à la
même situation créant un sentiment
d'insécurité grandissant chez les élus
yves binois élu maire de plaisir depuis
2013 joséphine coleman ce berger ressent
cette augmentation de la violence
je compatis auprès de mes collègues par
rapport à tout ce qu'ils ont pu subir
moi même j'ai eu il ya quelques temps
aussi des agressions et aussi j'ai reçu
des menaces
par écrit j'ai reçu un caillou sur sur
une jambe
alors ça pas gravissime et le geste en
soi n'est pas acceptable
il n'y a pas eu vraiment de poursuites
par rapport à ça il va falloir aussi que
la population comprenne que nous ne
devons pas être des punching ball on
doit pas être là des boucs émissaires de
tous et de tout ce stress bien sûr qui
est dans la société on est là au
contraire pour les accompagner du côté
de lévis saint nom la première édile and
green on le reconnaît elle n'a jamais eu
à subir cette violence mais souhaitent
tout de même plus de sanctions toute
mesure qui permettra de combattre ce
sentiment d'impunité et de rétablir
l'autorité du maire sera évidemment la
bienvenue à la violence envers les élus
est un sujet évidemment extrêmement
grave et qu'il faut combattre
on a eu quelques quelques exemples cet
été de deux mères qui avaient été
frappés insultes etc et pour lesquels il
n'y a eu que des 2 simple rappel à la
loi donc c'est évidemment absolument
inacceptable un souhait entendu par le
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti
depuis le 7 septembre les insultes
envers les mères sont désormais
qualifiées d' outrage impliquant la mise
en oeuvre de travaux d'intérêt général
cette semaine l'actualité c'est aussi le
dépistage géant de lakovic 19 organisée
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
nous vous en reparlerons dans un instant
avec notre invité
avant cela le témoignage de xavier
quintin directeur des activités de l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
au plus haut de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
les services de réanimation yvelinois
ont accueilli jusqu'à 190 patients il en
a fait partie hospitalisation placé en
réanimation puis transférés il est
aujourd'hui guérie il témoigne auprès de
ces auprès de mélanie poké pardon
la première suspicion et vers le 16 juin
mars à peu près où je me sens un peu
fébrile et j'ai réellement de la fièvre
à partir du barrage le 27
les symptômes effectivement se sont
aggravées la fièvre augmenté à plus de
39 depuis cinq jours quasiment et je
suis par ailleurs en contact avec une
infirmière pour un autre souci est saine
concrètement qui va me dire d'appeler le
je pense que moi et ça c'est très
important de le dire qu'à ce monde moi
je ne leur ai pas encore fait je monte
assez rapidement après être passé par là
le beuc de déstockage de déchocage
l'urgence je passe donc en chambre à
l'étagé
relativement rapidement l'agréable le
mans surpris je me rappelle de cette
cette sensation et puis après c'est un
petit peu le trou noir je regrette
puisque mon état va s'aggraver l'enjeu
montans en chambre j'estime vert vers
minuit à peu près à 5 heures du matin
mon état s'aggrave fortement très
fortement et très soudainement comme
dans l'air dans la plupart des cas
d'aggravation donc je suis placé en
réanimation effectivement sans en être
conscient
j'y reste jusqu'au 1er avril et le 1er
avril la décision est prise de m'envoyer
à rennes par tgv oui je vais commencer à
reprendre confiance en fait au moment où
je vais être exclu et l'excitation
elle intervient le 7 avril donc au bout
de dix et deux jours des problèmes de
concentration d'attention et de
mémorisation et ça en discutant avec des
médecins par la suite j'ai su que
c'était un des éléments qui étaient
assez fréquent chez les malades atteints
du pôle idées notamment notamment
inspiré de façon assez sévères la
deuxième la deuxième c'est qu'elle
s'appelle d'articulation à l'épaule
gauche notamment du bras gauche et des
problèmes d'amplitude peut pas faire
tous les gestes que je faisais avant et
la troisième c'est qu'elle s'est belle
cicatrice là en fait dû à l'intubation
leurs pratiques avant de transférer
jusqu'à mon réveil auraient pas
outre-mesure inquiet sur l'avenir
maintenant je me protège même si
effectivement je fais partie des
personnes qui pour l'instant sont très
peu susceptibles d'être contaminés mais
j'explique à terme je puisse l'être
notre invité de la semaine et marion
sinaly directrice départementale de
l'agencé régionale de santé de la rs
pardon des yvelines
[Musique]
mariant sinaly bonsoir et bienvenue
parmi les différentes opérations que
vous avez piloté donc avec la rs je
rappelle que vous êtes directrice
départementale de la rs dans les
yvelines
en début de semaine un dépistage géant
de lakovic 19 étaient organisées au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sur trois
jours à destination des entreprises
une opération assez inédites voire
unique en france
quel est ce bilan de ces trois jours
justement est ce que vous voulez en
faire le bilan
trois jours intensifs en plus j'imagine
oui tout à fait on a organisé cette
cette manifestation ce dispositif
à l'initiative de l'agglomération de 50
ans qui nous avait sollicités durant la
crise mais on n'avait pas pu le faire et
donc là comme on déploie ses opérations
de dépistage dans l'ensemble de la
région et notamment dans les yvelines
puisque ça correspond à la 16eme
opération condense mais pas d'envergure
si grande
on a proposé à l'agglomération de 50 ans
de pouvoir le faire à destination des
salariés des entreprises et donc on a eu
effectivement pas mal de passages on a
enregistré un passage à peu près de 1500
entre 1500 et 1600 personnes qui sont
venues se faire dépister sur les trois
jours et donc c'était vraiment donc à
destination des entreprises comme vous
me disiez est ce qu'il y a eu uniquement
des salariés des patrons des pme et tpe
des grandes entreprises qui sont venues
se faire dépister
c'était effectivement au départ à
destination des salariés des entreprises
mais également on avait une file pour
les patients prioritaires puisqu'on sait
que là une grande difficulté en ce
moment d'accès aux tests qu'on avait une
fiche spécifique pour les les patients
prioritaires symptomatique avec des
ordonnances ou bien des cas contacts de
cas positifs et qui aurait eu le petit
sms de l'assurance maladie qui leur
demande de venir se faire dépister et
donc on a accueilli ces gens là aussi on
a fait passer les messages à la fois via
l'agglo et les
les mairies des douze communes de saint
quentin en yvelines pour que ces
patients puissent être pris en priorité
donc c'était pour les salariés des
entreprises des collectivités locales de
la ville de saint quentin et pour la
population générale d'accor donc
vraiment assez complet sur le public que
vous avez accueilli
est ce qu'il ya des inquiétudes à avoir
au vu du nombre d'augmentations de cap
coz itif de le département mais
également en france alors au niveau de
la région ile de france
on le sait maintenant ça fait plus de 15
jours qu'on a dépassé les seuils
d'alerté qu'on est on a été classé en
niveau rouge par santé publique france
pour ce qui concerne les yvelines
ça fait dix jours qu'on a dépassé les
seuils d'alert à la fois sur le niveau
d'incidence puisque aujourd'hui on est à
peu près à 58 pour cent mille habitants
en termes d'incidence est à la fois sur
le taux de positivité on est à 5,9
aujourd'hui donc oui il ya une
circulation très active du virus en ile
de france dans les yvelines aussi même
si c'est un département où le virus
circule moins dans d'autres départements
franciliens notamment paris et la petite
couronne
mais ceci étant ça circule et c'est vrai
que sur ces opérations de dépistage
qu'on mène on constate aussi une
positivité plus importante
j'imagine en corrélation forcément avec
l'augmentation du nombre de tests ce ce
nombre d'augmentations de kaposi tiff
est ce que c'est parce qu'on teste plus
haut si aujourd'hui il ya une raison oui
c'est parce qu'on teste plus mais ceci
étant on constate que les taux de
positivité augmente nettement plus vite
que le taux de dépistage supplémentaire
donc c'est pas complètement
mathématiquement on peut pas s'y
retrouver
certes on dépiste plus donc on trouve
plus de positivité mais il ya aussi
quand même beaucoup plus de cas positifs
ça veut dire que le virus circule
beaucoup plus très bien beaucoup
beaucoup de chiffres alors bon faut-il
s'inquiéter est ce que il faut
s'inquiéter justement de segmentation
alors ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne faut
pas justement réduire les et aux
barrières est-ce que vous avez des
conseils justement de maintenir les
gestes barrière le port du masque
évidemment veillez toujours à garder une
distanciation et puis se laver les mains
respecter aussi la distanciation même
entre amis en famille c'est important
parce que on voit que voilà ce virus
circule et que les cas aujourd'hui
les taux d'incidence qui sont plus
important aujourd'hui c'est surtout
entre les tranches d'âge des 20 39 ans
parce que ce sont des évidemment la
tranche de la population qui voit le
plus de monde qui côtoie le plus de
monde qui a envie de sortir de voir de
la famille etc
et c'est là que le virus circule le plus
donc il faut vraiment être vigilant
d'accord et pour en revenir à ce
dépistage sur les trois jours au
vélodrome national de saint-quentin est
ce que vous avez eu des retours sur les
retards justement de résultats de
communication des résultats en verre
envers les salariés et les gens qui se
sont fait dépister
alors aujourd'hui n'y a pas de retard
sur cette opération en tant que tel on
s'était engagés à des résultats en 24 à
48 heures les engagements sont tenus les
salariés ont leurs résultats donc
là-dessus il n'y a pas de difficultés
après c'est vrai qu'on a accueilli des
gens on a proposé à des gens qui ne
trouvaient pas de rendez vous en ville
qui n'avait rien à voir avec l'opération
de pouvoir venir se faire dépister pour
qu'ils puissent être pris en charge
rapidement d'accord et quels sont les
prochains dépistage justement pour ceux
qui n'auraient pas eu la chance de se
faire dépister ou la chance en tout cas
l'occasion de se faire dépister
quels sont les prochains dépistage
prévus dans le département cadac la
semaine prochaine mardi 15 si je me
trompe pas on sera à chevreuse ma
mercredi 16 on sera à
villennes-sur-seine jeudi 17 à epône et
vendredi 18 à 120
et donc c'est un dépistage ces
dépistages sont ouverts au public à tout
le monde
exactement au public à tout le monde on
est sur la place de la mairie on enfin
il ya des adresses spécifiques et où
tout peut être dit ou sera disponible
par don sur le site de l' agence donc il
y aura toutes les informations et puis
les mairie communique évidemment donc
c'est destiné à tout le monde avec deux
fils toujours une file prioritaire et
une file pour les personnes qui veulent
venir se faire dépister mais qui n'ont
pas forcément de symptômes eh bien merci
beaucoup marion sinaly d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui dans ce premier set 8
l'hebdo de la saison et pour justement à
juste avant de refermer ce 7,8 l'hebdo
direction les vignes de d'avron les
fondateurs du domaine de la bouche du
roi ont présenté ce mercredi 9 septembre
le premier millésime de leur histoire à
leurs partenaires et notamment au
conseil départemental
un reportage de michael almy deux roues
à d'avron les stars du jour sont ces
bouteilles le millésime 2010 9 du
domaine la bouche
roy a été présenté ce mercredi 9
septembre dans les vignes yvelines oise
ce vin blanc et rouge est issu de la
première plantation de 2010 est de 3 ha
soutenue par le conseil départemental
des yvelines le premier millésime i il a
une couleur particulière puisque c'est
celui qui arrive après trois ans de
travail puisqu'on la vigne mais trois
ans à produire et donc surtout on est
très heureux d'avoir vu dans les cuves
se révéler vraiment le goût du terroir
et faire ses vins qui vont avoir le goût
du lieu où ils sont produits
c'était très excitant puisqu'on a suivi
ses cuves on a planté ses cépages en
fonction du terroir qui ici la
dégustation organisées ce jour-là permis
de tester le niveau de ses premières
vendanges qui se sont déroulés sur le
site yvelinois du 22 septembre au 7
octobre 2019 le millésime 2010 9 s'est
très très bien passé on a une très belle
maturité et surtout on présente pour la
première fois la typicité la singularité
de ces cépages sur ce terroir qui n'a
pas vu devine depuis très longtemps et
qui permet d'avoir des vins singulier
équilibré avec une grande pureté
aromatiques ces bouteilles de vin sont
vendus via le site de la bouche du roy
lé seront également distribués aux
partenaires locaux des alentours
en parallèle le domaine propose toujours
des visites de ses vignes au grand
public jusqu'à la fin du mois de
septembre
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 l'hebdo
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau résumé de l'actualité de la
semaine
avant cela retrouver l'information lundi
à 18h dans le 7-8 journal présenté par
grégory canalys vous pourrez revoir
également cette émission en replay sur
notre site internet tv 78 points com ou
sur notre application mobile tv 78
jusqu'ici je vous souhaite de passer un
très bon week end et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais